[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us a very special guest today and
that is mr big herc hey
so big hurt uh a lot of people might
know him from his prison youtube but i
actually know him from way back in the
day met this dude in car meets and he
had one of the most remarkable life
stories that i've ever heard uh
hopefully we'll get a nice background of
that whole thing i know it's a really
long story yeah so it's a lot we're
making youtube videos in prison no no no
no
tick tock youtube
prison tick tock
if you like to subscribe and i'll see
you guys next time
no i didn't have a cell phone in prison
i started after i got out but i met ryan
before i started my channel i had a
different business i had a clothing line
when i met him and i was in the cars and
that was like our initial passion
together and um i think i started the
youtube after i started youtube like a
couple years after yeah yeah way after
that so yeah um what got you into
youtube i still like random well youtube
you know when i was in a little
background i did 120 well since 120
months in federal prison from arm bank
robbery hostile takeover um i ended up
doing eight years eight months went down
in 2000 i got out in 2008 october
well why don't we rewind a little bit
because the worst has come out so fast
was this was this in california it was
in ventura it was on the news it was uh
i ran across the freeway high-speed
chase that's crazy what is that what
exactly is a
hostile takeover a hostile takeover is
when you come in ski math you tell
people to get on the ground you
basically take over the bank have
somebody jump over the counter um
somebody got hit with a gun i mean they
took money i mean it was just a whole
it was it was like you know something
you would see in a movie how many dudes
were there there was me a driver and
another gunman and i'm the only one
still alive out of that case oh [ __ ]
like like the law enforcement hit the
other two well when the other guy got
out he died of natural causes lupus and
the other guy
if you don't remember
um some years back a homeless guy got
shot like five times by lapd down there
he was they were doing a sweep um that
was my co-defendant he he went to prison
he went crazy oh [ __ ] got out with
homeless i remember there was that other
thing that happened in ventura when the
two dudes had like those machine guns
and stuff remember oh the body armor
guys
yeah that was the russian guys yeah yeah
we didn't go out like that don't do this
yeah
i wish i had
they caught me on the beach man did you
have any like
a warm-up hostile takeovers before you
did like a like yeah did you do like a
liquor store or something first
washington mutual i don't i don't want
to incriminate myself but i was doing a
lot of street [ __ ] you know and i when
that mentality i don't even know that
person today but you know when i speak
on
just different things that i see
junctures doing i live that life and i
know the mentality and you know i didn't
have a sense of just the consequence of
my actions but um you know like i said
if somebody you said hey man this dude
right here blah blah blah i'm like where
are you all right kick back you know and
i would you know i wanted to do i would
handle business man i didn't have
if i felt like i was i was just that
dude i had built up on my mind i was
that gangster dude and
and if something needed to be dealt with
so to me then the natural progression
was oh it hit a bank you know what i
mean i'd already that's a natural
progression
i knew the streets and um
and i didn't know these dudes
as far as like from my hood or anything
so it wasn't like i kind of jumped out
there with that but it was a purpose for
it because i went into prison and i
actually um learned some things about
myself and uh
and found a mentor and came out a better
person and that's where i came up with
the idea for fresh out while i was in
prison
just you know my thing when i was in
prison unlike a lot of people
i separated myself from everybody i
didn't have any homies you know a lot of
people go to prison they know somebody
hey man what's up oh you didn't know
anybody in there nobody i had nobody i
knew from the streets where did you go
to prison uh lawn park usp so i went to
lawn park u.s that's by our farm bro
it looks like a dungeon you know look at
castle they call it the castle long park
usp i went to the to the high the usp
then i went to um sheridan and then i
went to herlong i got out of her lawn
but um yeah man i just when i got in
there and i'm sitting around and dude
you it's like the sails literally like
me and me and ryan couldn't even stand
up together like this is how big like i
got to sit out for him to stand up you
can go like this and touch the walls
you can touch the feet i mean that's how
small it is the toilet's right here you
gotta kind of go around i mean this is
it's a it's a little it's a small
bathroom your bathroom is probably
about big of a sale maybe the sale is a
little bit smaller you got like two
people two people living in there and
long park the usp back then it was
serious man it was like you had major
crime bosses up in there cartel dudes um
you had guys in there you know the
average sentence in there was you know
30 years so there's a lot of life first
i've been down 20. oh my god i've met a
dude he had five lives plus a hundred
whoa i'm like damn dude they gave you a
hundred on top of the five
what you doing man
what did he do so if he he got one life
off so he still had four more but they
figured by the time you get all the
lights off you still got the hundred how
do you get a life off anyway god just
fighting in the law library trying to
peel but that process takes years
years
dude there's oh my god does he have a
good good sense of humor about it is
five
lives you try not to even tell nobody
how much time you're doing because you
don't want somebody to be like oh you're
short timing because i've had people say
oh man you only got you only got a ten
year oh man you you got another one in
you i said no i don't you got another
one
oh geez
yeah yeah you don't want to hang around
like lifers like dudes tell me that dude
you know like a dude like hey man you
know so-and-so right you know you know
that dude got life right you better
watch out with a man because if you're
around to do with life you don't know if
he's a predator if he's trying some
slick [ __ ] to try to get in cool maybe
see your mail address you know dudes to
see your mail address and send them out
at your mama's house you know dude it's
like there's a lot of predatory you got
to be really on and dudes are master
manipulators because they've been in the
system so long you've adapted you became
a creature of habit so at the highest
level there you have to really know
people and body language and and feel
and know what you're dealing with and if
you got certain people that you know are
possibly detrimental to your health you
have to be able to isolate them quick
and find out who they are and if you
need to deal with them neutralize them
because there's not a whole lot i mean
by neutralizing sleep with the fishes
neutralize them in the sense where you
either
find ways to not come in direct conflict
because it's going to be a night fight
because you're like you're a big dude
they're not going to they're not it's
going to be a jump situation because
most dudes have homies so when they see
it's like a you know that type of
situation i'm me being a decent-sized
dude i know that i would have to defend
myself in a way where i could possibly
kill somebody or two you know
chop somebody's neck you know you got to
do things you know gouge your muffin
eyeballs out you got to be ready because
it's not like it's not a handy hand like
literally you know you're going to deal
with somebody at a different level to
where you don't want them to have to
even come back a second time yeah and
set examples for people oh don't mess
with him yeah you know so that's the
type of environment it's very it's very
predatory like i said dudes in there you
know you're you're based off reputation
and then you know people are depending
on who you are dude they're googling you
oh what do you say he ain't for yeah
check see if he's lying i've seen dudes
there that were like
walking around oh man let's do either og
and then somebody show up and next you
know some information drop dude that
dude they
punish him punish him until he go from
from being good to next day bad
overnight like this that quick because
the homies the homies gonna do it to you
hey man we're gonna have a meeting up in
a gym then you go up in a gym man they
they gonna rat pack your ass you know
what's happening
they're gonna get up in there we're
talking and then all of us gonna look
whoo like
stop it i see that dude stomping penis
is out or no no none of that
[Laughter]
i know penises i don't know what the
[ __ ]
i was like yeah pack means that dude
you're getting packed out
[Music]
stomp your head everything i'm starting
to get your hopes up literally yeah it's
ambitious man no none of that yet is
that your first time in prison or did
you have other uh i mean i've been to
juvenile hall i've been to california
youth authority so i have been in
trouble previously
and um
you know i hadn't really had the
opportunity to heal myself and the thing
that was different in the feds is you're
dealing with grown man and in in that
situation i found a mentor who taught me
about myself you know i learned a lot
about myself i had a a brother up in
their older brother who laced me up i
had a
white dude who taught me a lot about the
law i learned a lot about the legalese
how to file motions how to help other
people i had another partner in there
who's korean who put me up on like
buddhist uh
buddhist meditation what was that guy in
there for um uh bank robbery you know
and we're still tied to the day though
all my friends that i made in there
and a lot of my friends were
multicultural which kind of threw off
the whole prison
politics situation because you know you
can't i can't go sit at your table yeah
you know i mean you got your table me
you can kind of outside like a little
bit but your homies like they're not
cool with that so you gotta navigate and
people like romeo and juliet exactly you
know like me talking to a white guy like
what are you talking to that white guy
for what are you doing over here people
are watching your every movement oh yeah
so it's a lot of that going on in there
but um yeah you know when i'm at the
juvenile hall for selling crack man
when i was younger and then i had uh did
time i did like six months in juvenile
hall for that and then i'd also i've
been in trouble i went to uh cya for my
involvement in a home invasion when i
was uh 18. so i had made some mistakes
man but it wasn't like i was out trying
to trace a drug habit or
um i had some crazy addiction or
anything like that i just was making bad
choices because i didn't have the right
guidance or mentorship
you know i was a straight-a student man
i mean like 4.0 i graduated 3.7 i mean
it was school was like i was always good
in school i wasn't stupid i had
you know i had my first business license
at
15 and a half 16 i started to close the
line you know i was skateboarding bmx
and i mean i actually wrote uh i think
shoe designs and nike
uh adidas to try to get on to try to
design before all these people
you know off-white and all them was
doing all this kanye i was riding these
people looking on the back of shoe boxes
trying to get on you know i was trying
[ __ ] before i sold drugs i was like man
maybe i can design shoes or maybe i can
design video games i don't know if you
guys remember in television the old
school i had in telugu i'm like i'm like
man i can make a game you know before i
knew what coding was and
i drew some little stuff a bunch of
different pages i wish i still had that
stuff fight worth a lot of money and i i
wrote them and sent it to them them i
sent it to coleco i sent this to atari
you know i was doing stuff in my hood
nobody was doing nobody told me to do
this stuff but i just figured cause it
was on yellow pages with no smartphone
yeah so i would look and then tv wasn't
nobody talking about this but i would
always be looking like business
magazines i'm like how do you do that
maybe i can do it you know let me try to
write them or looking for addresses you
know i made a demo table one time for i
wanted to you know do rap i sent it out
the different you know back in you know
back in the tape remember they had the
little cassette little address i tried
sending stuff in i tried all kind of
stuff it wasn't like crime was just my
only thing i tried other stuff before
you know and that's it just you know
that's what it fell into but
um yeah man it just took a long time for
me to learn but while i was in prison in
the feds is when i said you know what i
got to get out and help people and i
need to come up with something that
shows a different perspective of
somebody who's done time that's changed
their life to maybe influence some of
these people on the street differently
than glorifying and she wasn't glorified
about prison what did your mentor was he
in there for my mentor my the white guy
mentor was in there for making synthetic
heroin he was doing 30 years
he uh was ballin he actually was really
smart dude he had he taught me about
black's law about the congressional
letters
of like the congressional congress
letters um congressional acts he taught
me about um a lot about the the
constitution bill of rights just how to
shepardize cases how to file habeas
corpuses how to petition the u.s
attorney manual he actually put his
daughter through chapman college and she
worked for federal reserve so this dude
was like hi baby's super smart man a
genius dude but he was a heroin addict i
didn't know he ended up dying in prison
of heroin after i got out yeah dude told
me he overdosed in there yeah he died
here man sad man dude was hella smart
vietnam veteran but he was in there
doing 30 years for heroin and then my
other mentor the black guy he was in
there he was uh
he was like uh what do you call like a
truck heist used to do truck licks like
where you take the containers like vin
diesel [ __ ] yeah take your containers
and he would uh he would slang him to
like you know he had like um somebody
who would buy the the goods in their
lives like beverly hills cop yeah
you know like a container full of like
tvs or high-tech stuff or whatever the
case may be and he was making like you
know six figures a month had a
testarossa porsche on the street but he
he was different he was from south
central but he wore his pants up high
didn't sag you know very articulate um
you know it wasn't a gang member and he
made me look at myself like why do you
why do you act like this you know why
you why would you talk like this why
would you say this why do you do that
and he started pushing a lot of
spiritual stuff on me like stuff like to
read that opened my mind up to expand
just how i looked at myself because i
never had that i never had nobody like
really giving me that game i'm just
running around just trying [ __ ] what
would he ask you to read what were you
talking about conversations with god uh
neil uh neil scott uh neil donald scott
walsh um deepa tropa
um sylvia saint um just a lot of
spiritual stuff like different types of
uh articles and books that just made you
think about your existence
about religion things that contradicted
religion things that um other spiritual
uh
insights that made you question your
purpose in life and things about like uh
culture
you know being black what it means to
represent yourself how you carry
yourself and just put it in perspective
to see like look you know am i carrying
myself in a righteous manner am i just
out here act like a damn fool why are
you doing this and just making it making
me think a lot of people don't want to
think because it's painful yeah it's
like you makes you like wow man maybe
i've been you know messing up my whole
life maybe everything i've been taught
it's been a lie or you know i made these
mistakes but you got to own up to it and
in the process you're no longer a victim
when you're no longer a victim you can't
sit there and point the finger at nobody
oh my daddy oh my mama oh this and that
oh then you know you can't keep making
all the excuses you got to own up and
when you own up to something that means
now you're you have to create change a
lot of people don't that's why they
don't want to be continue to be a victim
because they don't have to change oh the
government oh the white man
oh crap oh crap
that's
[Laughter]
what was that turning point for you
because it's like was it like
immediately when he got into prison he's
like oh now's the time the turning point
is when i when we ran across that spike
trip on our freeway
the car literally turned around
also you guys actually were able to
leave the premises dude that's just the
high speed it was a crazy man we
they they we
left the bank
pulled out the bank coincidentally when
we pulled out a cop car bumped us i
don't know if you know
but see well we were in the bank
when i was in the bank and i'm telling
the dude to hurry up i'm looking after
when i gotta i gotta like m1 carbine i'm
like holding it down the security guard
i got everybody on the ground i'm
looking from the corner of my peripheral
i see a sheriff in a in a um rain suit
so i'm like oh i've been already here so
i'm like dude come on get a bed let's
get up out of here and he's still up in
there panic doing all this stuff and so
i'm like come on man i've run out he
comes out after me we jump in the car we
pull out we're in a ford white four
escort four-door pull out cop pulls
right behind us boom oh my god man he
bumps up oh we we take off we hit up the
street and there's like a almost like a
like a like an area like this kind of
like we have like uh different types of
businesses and dumpsters
and we pull in we pull in this one
that's kind of open
and the cop gets out get out the car and
we're like damn dude what's up all ready
is over
and like we're sitting there thinking
i'm gonna do guns it guns it pass the
cop boom go around and we go to another
little industrial place where we had
another car hidden which was a navigator
so we switched jumped out that the car
jumped in the navigator now three black
guys early in the morning navigator we
pull out the cops are swarming already
we pull out and when a cop sees us and
they we look i mean dude they know we
we're out of pocket we're we're
potential suspects we pulled out
high-speed chase 101 freeway ventura
heading down ventura like past thousand
oaks and dude they were honest it was
raining it was just you know helicopter
no one checked the weather before the
robbery
the right it should have i mean you know
what to be honest that morning
there was a sign that i wasn't supposed
to go see that's why you got to know
it's not gut feeling you got to know the
signs my mom called me like seven in the
morning asked me what i was doing oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's crazy dude i'm sitting
there with this this army fatigue thing
on just waiting for the pickup dude my
mom's like what are you doing i said oh
i'm watching the news she's like did you
watch the bachelor last night i'm like
yeah you know
you know i mean the finale or the finale
it was a big deal it was the first
season and i'm like when i got the phone
i'm like something you know what i mean
i didn't catch it yeah that was like a
sign from universe like dude just stay
home i would have stayed home i'd have
been cool yeah i stayed home man i had a
house i was living right off of beverly
glen and beverly hills nice area big
nice spot and it's like ah man i went
took the dog out i'm like you know just
feel right you know but you know you try
to shake it off oh man maybe you know
man i was just nervous maybe a big day
no it was a sign man and i didn't i
didn't read the signs so like i said we
got in a high speed chase
spike strip they let they let the canine
i guess ran into the car i jumped out of
the car like lightning speed jumped over
to senator divider ran across the 101
freeway ran up an embankment i don't
know i thought i was gonna try to hide
somewhere and they caught me on the
ventura
beat boardwalk
on the boardwalk and and with the ocean
right there like like eight cops get on
the ground honestly that's got on the
ground i wasn't gonna resist get on the
ground and that's when i had the
epiphany like
this is a wrap this is it
this is you know this the game's over
yeah you know gangsta the game's over
and i looked down to the ocean and that
was my last vision i'm like man i'm
going to be i've just seen the ocean
heard the waves i'm like this is crap
that's it right that last time i seen
the ocean for the next decade
you know and that's when i had to piss
me so when i got once i put the
handcuffs on me i immediately said in my
mind i'm gonna discuss myself from these
two dudes bad it's bad it's a bad bad
juju man bad energy and i went from
there and i just took my path from that
day on i started studying and just
changing the way i looked at life and
then that's how i met these mentors on
my journey wow wow you mentioned that
there was that moment that you could
have just stayed home but do you think
that if you stayed home like there would
have been another time in the future
that you would have like gotten caught
in the same thing because that that
wouldn't have been your turning point
then you know the only way maybe would
have been turning point maybe if i would
have saw the news and saw these dudes
got killed or something happened then i
thought oh that could have been me you
think that would have snapped you out of
it it might have but coincidentally i
mean not coincidentally it's that but
both those dudes are dead
so it's i had a greater purpose they're
both dead man one dude he got out before
me dude he died like a couple months
after i got out just got sick and the
other guy he never he lost his sanity
went crazy stopped showering just went
crazy up in there man and you know he
was a straight before he went locked up
he was a good dude but went crazy got
out lived on skid row
living in the tent got killed on skid
row
yeah so you know there's a lesson to be
learned man and people think like oh man
this and that and dude you know until
you get up in there and you start seeing
what's going on it's a totally different
thing and it's like it changes some
people for the better some people for
the worse but a lot of people come out
and they don't they don't get it because
they're not strong enough to be you got
to be an individual to separate yourself
to build and make it through that that
that trial and tribulation without
getting caught up because once you start
hanging with the homies and you try to
stop
it's hard man because like oh no you're
not gonna walk the yard with us so you
start something you gotta want you don't
ever start something you can't finish
and that's the thing that's why i never
tried to like go hang out oh come on man
come on now i'm cool i'm cool a lot of
people talk about how like as soon as
you go in you need protection and stuff
like that right but for you you didn't
it was fine you didn't get bothered no
no you just mind your own business yeah
no homies no no og's no my hood wasn't
up in there none of that man i but what
i did was i knew how to talk to people
and i knew how to kind of read energy so
i would know you could walk by a dude
and tell i do the killer you know if you
have a conversation with a dude he's
like oh man i'm doing life man i don't
know what i did i'm like
dude he's like i know you dude you were
a hit man you know i could toast you
[Laughter]
you're a goddamn killer man but yeah
it's
cool i did
i don't know why i'm even here yeah
they have government you know what i
mean
there's a lot of people in jail that
think they're innocent
but like they didn't do it in their mind
they want to think that i'll be free one
day and they're you know and i have seen
you know fortunately i have seen some
guys who had lice who are out now out
someone got pardons some got laws
changed so they got out through drugs
but like you know most these guys you
know they started hearing about because
most guys don't really tell you you hear
from someone somebody else like hey man
you know so-so dude they got like 20
bodies on their case like goddamn 20
bodies they're like yeah and you see the
dude what's up big hurt
like damn man he's not you know it's
like dude this dude they were out there
taking him up without you know but
nobody nope no killer that's a stupid
thing no killer in jail i miss you the
killer see these dudes out here oh i'm a
i'm a hitter i'm a
i'm a shooter nobody i've never met
nobody in prison
bro
scared of definitely they get indicted
you get called up like dude they're
gonna bring more it's scared to death
nobody in prison has ever admitted that
they killed anybody but everyone all the
rappers are oh my god
rico oh rico man rico you don't beat you
plead out
rico
you know you hear him talking right
wrong rico rico you do not you do not
want a rico cce bro you know how hard is
the big man explain nico rico is a rat
it's a racket series influence
corruption organization basically being
an organized crime gang right but they
take down the whole unit and what they
do is they see now
these guys don't tell my gang members
that's rico because that's what happened
to the ysl right now
yeah
dude you do you you never want to go on
label when you go to prison they say are
you part of a gang you never say you're
part of a gang oh what did that tattoo
mean oh man that's life that my mom got
there for me
[Music]
you